jim jordan is the ranking member of the
house judiciary committee congressman
how can the police possibly be the cause
of rising crime rates
yeah no they're not of course i mean
anyone with common sense understand that
i think what americans don't like trey
is is they don't they don't like this
attack on the individuals who put on the
uniform risk their lives and bust their
tail every day for us that's what they
don't like i mean this really shouldn't
surprise us so that this increase in
crime we're seeing this is when i told a
group the other day when you defund the
police you shouldn't be surprised when
you get more crime uh but to then turn
around and blame the very people who
bust their tail for us is just so out of
step just so wrong and the american
people see through it and your monologue
was right on target
well jimmy i'll tell you how boring my
life has gotten i'm actually watching
house committee hearings on c-span and
i've been watching you a lot lately and
you're as prepared as you ever were but
you seem particularly interested in the
first amendment at least with some of
the committee hearings i've been
watching
yeah i mean look i think i think our our
first amendment liberty is every single
one of them you're right to practice
your faith your right to assemble right
to petition your government freedom of
the press freedom of speech i think
they've all been assaulted over the last
year by the left uh particularly in in
light of these lockdowns everything else
they're doing to us but what the
attorney general did a week and a half
ago during this hearing we brought this
to light but when he issued that memo
basically setting up a snitch line on
parents who show up at school board
meetings to stand up for their kids and
make sure this racist anti-american
curriculum critical race theory is not
taught in our schools what he did was so
wrong and to see then the very next day
after that hearing the national school
boards association who started this
whole thing to see them apologize for
the letter they sent that's just
something you don't see too often i
would like for the attorney general to
rescind his memo hopefully he will we've
asked him to we're going to continue to
investigate this but this is as wrong as
it gets and americans understand it
you know congressman um i was once a
prosecutor many many moons ago and i was
a federal prosecutor so i started going
through my head the list of federal
crimes i mean crime rates are soaring
where can the feds help and i got to be
honest it never entered my mind that
starting with the parents of school
children in virginia should would be the
very best use of our time and resources
for the department of justice never
entered my mind
no it's it's ridiculous and again i
think i said this in the hearing train i
said it because i mean it i think the
the attorney general's memo is maybe the
last straw americans have had it with
this attack on on our first amendment
rights and on our overall freedoms i
think this is the last straw i think
when you start telling moms and dads oh
government knows more about what's good
for your children what's best for your
children than you do i don't think i
don't think americans i don't think
parents i don't think moms and dads are
going to stand for that and you're
seeing i think an awakening a
reawakening and an embrace of freedom
from the people of this great country
they're tired of what they've seen from
their government they're tired of
statements like what what congressman
omar made trey there was a week last
spring i will never there was a week
last spring where the week started off
with congresswoman talib saying not that
we should defund the police which is a
terrible idea of course she said no we
should get rid of police the week ended
if you remember with the trial judge in
minneapolis admonishing maxine waters
for the ridiculous things she said while
the jury was deliberating and in between
those two events in the united states
house of representatives the democrats
introduced legislation to add four new
associate justices to the united states
supreme court to pack the court all in
five days they did that hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else